[Music]
black hat is directed by Michael Mann
and stars Chris Hemsworth and as a story
about a computer hacker who's freed from
jail to go after another more evil
computer hacker who's actually killing
people with his computer hacking
abilities it's largely about the hunt
for that man as well as a romance that
blooms between Chris Hemsworth and his
new partner I'm a huge fan of Michael
Mann I mean Heat
The Insider which i think is very
overlooked nowadays collateral is one of
my all-time favorite movies and inspired
me a lot in my opinion he's the director
who's able to film City nightlife at its
best
he makes it look edgy and gritty and
awesome and black hat in my opinion does
look very good now a lot of people are
confusing shakey cam with handheld
cameras are two very different things
Michael Mann is excellent with handheld
camera T of collateral he really
understands that artform and in this
movie he has beautiful shots great
action sequences and shootouts and a lot
of really good imagery the tone is very
inconsistent however and the pace drags
and drags from time to time but overall
I would not say Michael Mann is the one
to blame for this movie not being good
because it's not very good at all my
issue with this movie is the script the
script is kind of awful and I mean
ungodly terrible the characters in the
movie are incredibly boring and
unforgivably dull and it's not entirely
due to Chris Hemsworth not really
fitting in as a computer hacker a lot of
it is due to the dialogue in the writing
of these characters in the script and
the fact that the movie becomes
increasingly more implausible as it goes
along to the point where you just don't
really care anymore and you're just like
where is this movie really going it's
honestly a long boring series of
conversations about computer hacking and
some computer experts have actually
really praised the film for getting
certain small details correct and others
have said that some of it is just
laughable but overall it's such an
inconsistent movie that feels like
sometimes there's a gunfight and you're
like wow Michael Mann really understands
these shootouts and these action
sequences and they're really well done
and the audio feels realistic it's not
all Hollywood eyes it feels echoey like
it's actually there and Michael Mann's
signature handheld photography works so
well for those scenes but then all of a
sudden there's all the
CGI sequences in which a swooping
perfectly level symmetrical CGI image of
a camera going through computer wiring
and stuff like it doesn't fit it doesn't
mesh with the more handheld and grimy
low-budget on purpose cinematography now
all of a sudden got these CGI images of
like you know like panic room with David
Fincher we did with panic room or that
the camera would go across things and
through locks and through floors it was
really cool in that movie because the
entire film felt that stylized but when
you have a film that feels purposefully
so low-budget and then all of a sudden
all these random CGI shots it just
doesn't mesh after I saw the movie I was
reading through the IMDB message boards
and one user said a better title for
this movie would have been beefcake
super nerd which I completely agree with
because I like Chris Hemsworth he's a
very likable actor as a great screen
presence and he's a talented actor I buy
him as Thor I bought him as a racecar
driver I do not buy him as a super nerd
hacker computer genius I mean when does
he hack does he fit it into his daily
five-hour routine at the gym blackhat
was a long unfortunately boring movie
that sprung to life whenever there was
an action sequence because Michael Mann
understands that so well it has
beautiful nightlife cinematography but
the script is filled with so many stupid
dialogue scenes that you just can't get
into because you don't care about any of
the characters the villains once
eventually revealed are just ugly guys
who want money and stuff like they have
no motivation it's just stupid it's the
most cliched contrived villains the
script is bad I have no idea why
director as talented as Michael Mann
signed on to this movie that being said
I'm going to give blackhat a c-minus I
wouldn't really recommend checking this
one out guys
so guys two things first off my buddy
josh mokuba who runs the YouTube channel
between the sheets or the casual mafia
as it is known is trying to get 10,000
subscribers before his birthday at the
end of the month and he did an interview
with me a few months back in which he
asked me a whole bunch of questions
about my relationships and sex and all
of that stuff it's very rated our video
and I just I speak my mind I'm super
candid and totally completely rude and I
hope you enjoy it too go check it out
and give him a sub because he's my buddy
and he's trying to get 10k
and he works super super hard and I
think he totally deserves it all so I'm
very excited to bring you guys my very
first episode of retro rewind very very
soon
all about Toonami the programming block
on Cartoon Network and Adult Swim that
popularized anime in the late 90s I'm
going to be going super in-depth about
it I actually have been in contact with
people who work for Adult Swim who are
going to be behind the video I have
three incredible guests so far I went
from one to now three and I cannot wait
to share this with you guys is going to
be so much fun and I hope you enjoy it
as always thank you so much for watching
and if you guys like this you can click
right here and get stuck Manoj
[Music]